on the first running of the building the
lady was standing there knocking on the
glass trying to get someone's attention
try and get into the doors
I'd actually did three loads up and down
the stairs looking into the link
building and on the third round I was
looking in there wondering what a
problem was why she didn't go somewhere
else to get a coffee after she's been
told you know you're not getting inside
and then obviously getting at the gunman
or the alleged offender
opened a bag up and revealed ganondorf
to get rid of her and she went running
on the stage to the garden gun gun got
in the blue bag and I was out in Martin
Place yeah I saw the gunman yep
it was quite tall pretty late 40s and
that along with white sleeve shirt on is
ID with the black first mommy was very
calm
I'm he was just pacing he's looking out
into the lift well and I said the people
of the customers still sitting down at
their tables that was for drinking but
I'm not sure how it looked they were to
what was going to go on what was going
to unfold but they were locked in and
they were where they're locked in